you can feel that sort of sense of
survival that primal instinct that you
all have and your adrenal glands are
going you're scared
you're petrified
beast is about a family that is in peril
that is in pain did mom shoot someone
please this little bump right here
that's you
i still miss her every day their
relationship has been strained so they
take this trip to africa where mom was
from
this is my chance to reconnect with the
girls they're going back to her village
to her roots
where is everybody
hello
what happened in here
what did this
i've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks
without eating its prey
lions don't do that
at least no lion i've ever seen
snore
you've got a family that's going through
an unimaginable situation now they
encounter this rogue lion and they must
fight for their lives
[Music]
breathe slow down we're in his territory
now
[Music]
this isn't just any line this lion he
was part of a tribe that's been
split up broken up by poachers the lands
are taken from the animals their prides
are killed and in the end they will
strike back
one side is fighting for his daughters
and on the other side he's literally
fighting for his life
our director did an amazing job creating
a energy around this film don't emerge
the lion is coming from everywhere
but you're not sure when it will come
that's the reason that i will go to the
theater to see a movie it puts you in
that mind state of survival it is an
experience like no other
you